I was listening to an interview with you
and you told the story
of a young man who deliberately ran over
another man and killed him
could you tell that story for our
viewers and listeners
well um it has to be said that was a
peculiarly horrible case
the man who drove the victim
um clearly was found by the jury to have
done it deliberately
but what he couldn't have planned was
trapping him underneath the car he
couldn't have envisaged that happening
he couldn't have known that it would
happen it probably never crossed his
mind that it could happen
but it having happened he then drove for
nearly a mile uh with the man trapped
under his car
and by the time he stopped there wasn't
a lot of man under car left but there
was quite a lot of man up the road
um
and
so from the family's point of view it's
very hard to think of
anything more painful to come to terms
with this would have been
um slow death because he could have be
heard screaming uh which is why people
turn their cars to follow
um
it must have been peculiarly painful and
drawn out
so if you want an example of how a
family facing the worst sort of crisis
um deals with it
that would be quite a good case to take
it has to be said the degree of
criminality
is
um about as serious as you can envisage
but in terms of the way the law looks at
it it would not Merit the same sort of
sentence as if
um he'd been shocked by the defendant
when I began to do murder trials at the
bar the average sentence for murder was
the sentence is any one sentence is life
imprisonment but a judge's job is then
to say
how long a defendant must serve a
prisoner now must serve before he or she
can apply for parole
the average time when I first came to
the bar was between 10 and 15 years the
average time now is far closer to 25
years and that is because of legislation
that has been brought in
specific laws so for example
um if you kill someone with
a gun
um the starting point is 30 years
minimum before you can apply for pero
if you kill someone with a knife or
other weapon taken to the scene in
certain circumstances almost all
circumstances where knives are used in
public will be covered here
the starting point is 25 years for all
others the starting point is 15. now the
starting point isn't the finishing point
it can go up or it can go down
and those are the guidelines for
adults that say anyone 18 and over they
are different for people under 18 and
lower
um but
you can see immediately can't you that
somewhere along the line an awful lot of
people are gonna walk out of prison
primarily men who have spent
decades
perhaps as long as they had lived out in
the community
in prison
perhaps longer
in prison they are living in a male
society in which
they are never really challenged to take
responsibility for their day-to-day
lives
they are given some help in learning how
to manage their lives but they're never
responsible for really what happens
they've
almost never had a normal relationship
with
anyone certainly no woman
um
not necessarily someone they really love
they've never lived with children
for
you know since they were young really
young now I've only got to say that for
you to see that
if we think they are going to walk out
and fit seamlessly back into society
we're living in a Cloud Cuckoo Land
foreign